the post office is in trouble it's lost
money for 13 years straight
putting it in what experts say is a dire
financial situation
that's bad news for a service that
delivers everything from medication to
social security checks if you want to
know the reason for this
just take a look at a first class
postage stamp
it guarantees mail delivery anywhere in
the united states
even to the bottom of the grand canyon
and to cover the cost of the trip
the post office charges a flat rate of
55 cents
these two things mail that's universal
and affordable
make up the mission of the post office
the service is back in the news as part
of an ongoing political debate
but problems started years before as the
goals of the post office came into
conflict
creating a financial situation that has
raised questions about what the usps
should do and how far males should be
expected to go
the modern postal service we know today
emerged in 1970.
that year 152 000 postal workers walked
off the job
to protest pay and working conditions
halting much of the nation's mail
president nixon declared a national
emergency and called in federal troops
to sort the backlog
i have just now directed the activation
of the men of the various military
organizations
to begin in new york city the
restoration
of essential mail services part of the
reason for the postal crisis was that
congress held the purse strings
at the time the post office was a
cabinet-level agency and almost 25
of postal revenue came through
congressional appropriations
and all important decisions from wages
to setting postage rates
were made by congress this led to
artificially low postage rates which
were popular
but also created a stagnant postal
infrastructure
david tremble of the government
accountability office said oversight for
the post office was similar to other
government agencies
the post office was actually a part of
the federal government it was a
department
and as a department congress played a
much more
active role in a lot of operational
decisions
kevin kozar from the right-leaning
american enterprise institute
said it made running a nationwide
logistical system difficult
you had all these conflicting demands
that
flowed through the public through their
representatives and
into the post office department to deal
with these issues congress decided to
let the government agency run itself
more like a business in 1970 it passed
the postal reorganization act
which gave the agency more independence
in managing its operations
but independence came with a catch the
post office had to pay for everything
itself
from operations to employee benefits
congress doesn't pay for any of its
regular
operations nor does it have any say over
postage rates you sort of have this um
organization that's created that's got
sort of um
competing pressures on it having a sort
of a public role or public service
mission of serving every community
while at the same time operating
in a business-like fashion so that their
operations
financed uh all of their costs the usps
benefits from not having any competition
in delivering mail
to american mailboxes by law it operates
a monopoly over what has come to be
known as market dominant products
the letterbox in front of your home or
in the lobby of your apartment building
nobody else is allowed to get into that
other than the postal service
this covers categories like first class
mail marketing mail and periodicals
which make up the majority of its
revenues other services like package
delivery are open to competition from
companies like fedex and ups
this new postal business model worked
because mail volumes kept
increasing through the 20th century the
postal service benefits from having
economies of scale the more mail it
processes the less it costs to deliver
each letter this is crucial for a
business infrastructure that is expected
to deliver
mail across the united states the usps
has built out this infrastructure to
fulfill its universal service obligation
or uso this is a collection of laws
practices and expectations for how the
post office should serve
every american the specifics of the uso
are vague
but generally it has come to mean
affordable six day a week
mail delivery regardless of distance or
mail volume
over the years the post office has
tackled mail delivery in a variety of
ways
using pneumatic tubes sleds and segways
even today there are postal routes where
mail is delivered entirely by boat
postal service is often trying to do a
lot of different things at the same time
which is tough and it started getting
tougher in the 21st century
the internet offered a much quicker way
to communicate and in 2001
mail volumes began to decline these
declines prompted congress to pass
another set of consequential reforms in
2006.
the postal enhancement and
accountability act was intended to
streamline the rate setting process
by allowing price flexibility on
competitive products like packages
while at the same time putting a price
cap on first class mail
that was tied to inflation it was meant
to help the post office
but it did the opposite a short time
after it was enacted about 12 months
the united states slid into a recession
mail volumes and revenues started to
plunge
and the postal service struggled to find
the money
to put in the retiree health benefits
fund the retiree health benefits fund
was another requirement in the law that
mandated the postal service pre-fund
health benefits
to the tune of over 5 billion dollars
per year
all the while the post office was
expected to maintain universal service
to approximately one million new
addresses per year
a tall order when postage rates couldn't
be raised beyond the inflation cap
and while package volumes were growing
they weren't enough to cover the losses
from first class mail
the agency began defaulting on its
healthcare payments in 2012
causing debts and unfunded liabilities
to balloon to more than double
annual revenues for over a decade the
government accountability office has
classified the postal services financial
situation
as high risk and in need of
congressional action
at stake is the future of what has been
since this nation's
founding the right of every american to
send and receive mail
the fact is without some important
changes to the law that shape our
business model we cannot survive
as a self-financing entity without
legislative and regulatory reform
our net losses will continue to grow i
hope we can agree
that the financial state of the postal
service is unacceptable
and needs to be fixed several reform
bills have been introduced in congress
to address the burden of pre-funding
health care and some also
include proposals that would limit the
scope of the universal service
obligation
do we need six day a week delivery
should there be a delivery to every
location in the country should you have
uh is it right to have a single rate
whether you're mailing a letter across
the street or to alaska or to hawaii
these are sort of elements of service
that we've expected as a
you know as a community or society for
the post office to provide
but if you're requiring them to live
with these constraints
then the question is how do we how do we
fairly
pay and cover those costs but
legislation that changes the uso has
been difficult to pass
in part because the post office remains
so popular with americans
and experts say any operational changes
run the risk of inevitably affecting
service for some stakeholders
postal policy is very difficult to get
enacted
and the reason is that the major
stakeholders all want
things and these things often are in
tension with one another
but experts say if americans want the
post office to survive they may need to
decide how frequently they need mail
delivery
and if a 55 cent stamp is enough to take
their letters the distance
however far that might be